[Musique]
ça va tu vois un café quelque chose
non c'est bon quoi je dois vous annoncer
une nouvelle
c'est quoi cette grande nouvelle je ne
sais pas si c'est une grande nouvelle en
tout cas aujourd'hui avec mathieu on a
emménagé ensemble sérieux aux poules
bah ouais ça fait un an qu'on est
ensemble donc normal quoi ça fait sept
ans que je suis avec lorie où il pense
enfin à 5 en général de 7 ans taiwo mais
non mais n'importe quoi je pète gamin
vous savez pas vous occuper d'un 4ème et
[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi être un père
responsable n'était pas obligé de direct
non mais tu as raison je n'arrive pas à
m'occuper d'un chien je vais pas
m'occuper d'un bébé je prends les
comptables à mes frères c'est du taf
ça fait du bruit ça pue ça tout seul
loupé la partie c'est mon appart donc
ouais ok d'accord mais je n'imagine pas
que ça soit on tue jamais dit me wade et
ses 7 ans chez que ma copine on est fou
c'est ça ok mais bon on imagine par
exemple c'est moi qui ramène une meuf
par exemple tout à l'heure t'es chiant
j'ai prévu de rester en famille et
qu'aurélien là d'accord donc le chien ça
fait aurélien c'est juste un chien il
n'a pas de cerveau serait lui parler
comme ça il n'a pas de conscience doit
être un bon père ouais ça arrive super
ça apprend à installer de relations de
confiance entre le père et l'enfant le
plus jeune âge aux nous tuent des bisous
on fait peur donc que la meuf
j'anime seuil est cette fille que tu
dragues la rencontre comme on en fait je
regardais mes amis facebook et après je
regardais mes amis d'amis facebook et
doivent fil en aiguille je tombe sur mes
amis d'amis d'amis facebook parce que
battre à bout de bois et là je tombe sur
inès martinet à temps grand corps malade
si notre collège une espèce de gothique
un peu soul où elle était tombée en
cours du ps et du coup avec sa
belle-fille on l'avait appelé grand
corps malade disco brevets grand corps
malade
grand corps malade est devenu beau corps
bien foutu donc femme et vos yeux et pas
de gros mots dont on obtient toutefois
ça pour être cédés rien que ça vous
n'avez pas changé et vous êtes avait
perdu de vue depuis le collège
ben non moi je suis hyper fidèle en
amitié pas ton amitié d'ailleurs c'est à
dire bah je suis fidèle aussi sur
d'autres plans quelqu'un veut te deum ou
soupe à étoiles naissent alors je fais
quand tu as vu maintenant on va te dire
que dire
j'étudie les marchés pour une grande
banque d'investissement tamoil du pitti
ouailles on vient d'acheter un petit 90
mètres carrés
ils ont un petit copain ou ouais ouais
j'ai un petit copain et on va se marier
même génial
trop bien waouh voici donc un petit 90
mètres carrés
ouais bah forcément on a prévu une
chambre pour un enfant tu as un pareil
avec l'arrivée d'aurélien il me faudrait
une chambre plus petit garçon jeu les
castrais je pense oui c'est un chien
avant que tu appelles la police je suis
plus de bruit je pense qui dort en plus
je vais pas me de couches
mais quand tu dis on va se marier tu es
sûr de ce choix parce que c'est quand
même un truc important dans une vie oui
mais là je g5 c'est le moment ouais
c'est même avec tous les divorces qui
ouais mais j'aime tellement mon âme
ouais il est super il a une vie
incroyable mais bien vous voyez
peut-être qui sait c'est le mois de
février dans le calendrier des pompiers
de paris
ah ouais ouais ouais je vais très bien
celui qui est assainie avec alors 5 5
les groupes et c'est lui moi j'ai fait
le casting justement dakar reliant la
piste partout alors vous savez ce qui
serait super que vous veniez tout ça mon
mariage
ouais ouais ouais ça me fait super
plaisir pour se rappeler le bon vieux
temps quand on savait pas ce qu'on
allait faire de nos vies ben hamidi
moi j'ai hâte personnellement ou là des
files moins ça fait super plaisir nous
voir salut bayrouiste à bientôt au
mariage
c'est un rêve de houmous
cyprien salut c moi ça va vous en faites
une tête
qu'est-ce qui se passe tout va bien à
park grand corps malade va se marier
avec une sorte de pompier extrêmement
musclée voilà alain taf de ouf et elle
vit dans un petit 90 mètres carrés
notre fils a pissé partout notre fils
ressent beaucoup le chien de la voisine
[Musique]